قالت مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للشؤون الشرق الادنى بربراليا خلال جلسه
استماع في مجلس الشيوخ قالت ان الرئيس
بايدن كان واضحا في انه ملتزم بضمان عدم
حيازه ايران على السلاح النووي على
الاطلاق وان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل وسيله
لضمان ذلك وبشان لبنان قالت ان الادارات
تدرس خيار فرض عقوبات للدفع باتجاه اختيار
رئيس
لبنان
وفي قضيه اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقله اعتذرت
المسؤوله الامريكيه عن التاخر في تقديم
التقرير المحدث بشان مقتلها للجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه وقالت انها تتوقع ان
تطلع عليه اللجنه قريبا
وفي شان التونسي قالت المسؤوله الامريكيه
ان واشنطن تلحظ اغلاقا متواصلا لمساحات
المجتمع المدني وضغطا على النشاط
السياسيين
وينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر
الحسيني انا بكناصر نصر لو طلعنا على هذه
الجلسه وما قدمت مساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه لشؤون الشرق الادنى بخصوص
الملفات ايران لبنان وتونس
نعم بالفعل هي مجموعه من القضايا طائفه من
القضايا او الاشكاليات العربيه التي تخص
العالم العربي والتي سئلت بشانها فيخص
ايران لا جديد حقيقه في الموقف قالت ان
اداره بايضا لن تسمح الى ايران بالحصول
على ذلك السلاح النووي ولكن اداره بايدن
كما تقول ايضا ما زالت تسعى للحوار وتعتبر
ان الدبلوماسيه هي ابرز وافضل وسيله
للحصول على نتائج مع الجانب الايراني دون
ان تعطيها الكثير او المزيد من التفاصيل
حول
الحاله التي وصلت لها المفاوضات هل هناك
وساطات مثلا من سلطنه عمان الى اخره لم
تدخل في كل تلك التفاصيل فيما يخص لبنان
واضح جدا ان الولايات المتحده من خلال
تصريحات المسؤوله الامريكيه مهتمه جدا
بالوضع وكيف يتطور من حيث السياسه
الداخليه اللبنانيه لكن الاهم والابرز في
ذلك التصريح الخاص بلبنان انها تقول ان
الولايات المتحده تعمل مع عدد من الشركاء
لا تحدد الوزيره حقيقه من هم هؤلاء
الشركاء هل هم عرب ام اوروبيون ام قوه
سياسيه لبنانيه لدفع البرلمان اللبناني في
عمليه الاختيار الرئيسي البلاد اذا هناك
تعاون حاليا واستشارات والولايات المتحده
يبدو ان لديها ما يكفي من الصبر كي تتابع
ذلك الوضع لكن في الوقت ذاته وهذا الابرز
والجديد ان الولايات المتحده كما تقول
مساعده الوزير بلينكن تقول ان خيار
العقوبات الامريكيه من اجل الدفع
اللبنانيين والبرلمان الى اختيار رئيس يظل
قائما وبالتالي الولايات المتحده بدات
تعتقد لاننا لبنان وصل مرحله حرجه من
التراجع الاجتماعي والاقتصادي والسياسي
ربما حان الوقت حسب ما نفهم من هذه
التصريحات ان الولايات المتحده تفكر في
بضع عقوبات هل هي موجهه للدوله للحكومه
للهيئه اللبنانيه ام للقوى السياسيه
وزعمائها غير واضحا ثم دون ان تبدي اي
موقف حقيقي فيما يخص تونس تقول مساعده
الوزير بلين كان بانها بان الولايات
المتحده تتابع بقلق اذا ذلك الوضع في تونس
وان الولايات المتحده تعتبر ان الاوضاع
مشحونه وانها لامت ميزانياتها كي تواصل
دعم القوه العسكريه والشرطيه في تونس دون
ان تعطينا حقيقه
موقف واشنطن من رئيس قيس سعيد وتحركاته مع
ملاحظه امريكيه ان هناك تضييقا على
الحريات ولا اكثر من ذلك منطقه الشرق
الاوسط خصصت لها ودائما بشكل عام الكثير
من الاهتمام وقالت لاعضاء مجلس النواب ان
الولايات المتحده ترتكز الان على ثلاث
مبادئ من حيث التعامل مع المنطقه العربيه
الشراكه الدبلوماسيه والردع ايضا
وذكرت بعض الدول التي ستستفيد العام
المقبل من ميزانيات الولايات المتحده
للمساعدات الفلسطينيون مثلا سيحصلون على
300 مليون دولار وضع الدول مثل العراق
والاردن واسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك ناصر
الحسيني من